cuál es el panorama en la región tras
más de 700 días de pandemia y cómo se
compara con otras regiones del mundo
bueno lo que pasa es que américa es tan
tan amplia que tenemos varias
situaciones en algunos lugares apenas
está comenzando esta curva ascendente de
la variante otro pero lo que se ha
vuelto ya una constante es que son
muchísimos los contagios este es una
variante terriblemente contagiosa y lo
que está haciendo es que está poniendo
ya literalmente a millones de personas 1
resguardadas en su casa 2 fuera de su
trabajo lo cual y está impactando la
productividad y los sistemas de salud y
3 algunas aunque ahora son las menos en
porcentaje siguen siendo muchas las que
están recurriendo hospitalización sobre
todo las novatas bueno y en diciembre
pasado se publicó el índice mundial de
seguridad sanitaria que concluye que la
mayoría de los países del mundo no están
preparados para enfrentar una próxima
pandemia que se puede decir de la región
que nos ha enseñado esta pandemia con
relación a nuestros sistemas sanitarios
ah eso es muy interesante porque aún los
países que tenían muy buenos planes
respondieron mal aún los países que
tenían arsenales prácticamente listos
para una pandemia como es el caso de los
países nórdicos no lo hicieron de la
manera más adecuada ahora los países de
la región latinoamericana sobre todo que
no tienen planes si no tienen recursos
pues no pudieron responder seguramente
que el aprendizaje más grande para la
próxima pandemia que va a existir en
algún momento y tendremos muchas es
estar preparados y haber dedicado los
recursos monetarios suficientes para
poder responder como debe de ser